so you are the leader of your country
and you've heard all about nations
wanting to sign up for nato you want to
be part of the party but how do you join
here is your quick guide to a very
complicated process number one remember
that nato is a military but also a
political and geographic organization so
your fundamental question is is your
country in europe if the answer is no
then you might as well give up you're
not going to get through the door the
second thing is that you and people here
will have to critique your own democracy
do you have democratic institutions do
you respect minorities do you respect
the rule of law if you don't it's going
to be very very hard to get through the
nato process then your economy is it a
free open market economy make no mistake
nato is all about western values and if
your economy isn't those things again
it's going to be very hard to join up
but if you've got ticks in those boxes
you're doing well move on to the next
step a pretty fundamental one and that
is about your
military view
nato wants you to add to
trans-atlantic peace this is after all a
north atlantic organization and they're
going to want to see that you are
committed to spending a certain amount
of money each year and that you'll be
part of a security framework so let's
say that everything's gone well so far
nato is happy with the paperwork the
next thing is you'll need approval from
all 30 of the existing member states
that can cause the occasional problem
greece tried to block north macedonia
for ages but normally that will pass off
once you've got that approval there's
only one herd left and that is approval
from your own parliament when you get
that
congratulations you're in nato